[Music]
Las Vegas Nevada the 1950s
ahead mystic oasis in the middle of the
Mojave Desert in the aftermath of the
Second World War this is a chance to
escape the straitjacket of middle
America and let your hair down
the city of daytime some nighttime and
the people behind the whole show
the Mafia Las Vegas is the original
gangsters paradise
it was really unique to Las Vegas they
made the town and they made it the frost
post time
the Mafia makes millions of dollars in
legitimate gambling profits
that they have far more at stake an
illegal financial operation called the
skin the tamada tea is green cast
there's stuff from the outside there's
stuff from the inside
in there skimming the skim is money
siphoned off from the casinos counting
rooms before it can be taxed the amount
runs into the millions Mafia families
from across the nation each receive a
share in the skim based on the
percentage of ownership it holds in a
casino there is no record of the money
so it's extremely valuable to the mob
it's money that they can spend a hundred
percent of and have to account to no one
for
and good evening
radio DJ true Hawkins grew up in Las
Vegas during the 1950s his father was a
cashier at the Mafia run Riviera casino
but he didn't just count the money he
helped the mob run the skim one of his
jobs became to put hundred-dollar bills
in a lockbox drawer and set it on the
back counter and it disappeared and an
empty one showed up that was every day
five days a week quality was at work and
it was just understood that that box
didn't exist never happened nobody
talked about it
the Mafia holds a monopoly over the
gambling and hotel industry the biggest
employer in town going to work then
means going to work for the mob even
though it was illegal for employees like
Chu Hawkins Father Counting the skin was
just part of everyday life in my
father's eyes he was just doing his job
what I got to do that's what they told
me here's your paycheck you did it you
knew what was going on however the
approach of all of those mob-connected
guys they were perfect gentlemen to
everybody at work
[Music]
the Mafia keeps violent crime out of Las
Vegas they have too much at stake the
gambling profits and the skim are worth
millions and they don't want to attract
eat from the authorities or scare the
tourists away
[Music]